hey what's up guys I'm Kip EHD here
there is all kinds of stuff at CES
gadgets everywhere tech in every
direction to look at and play with and
lots of people but amongst all the chaos
I can tell you that there is for sure at
least a little bit of dope tech so this
is dope tech from CES 2016 first of all
there are not a whole lot of new
smartphones at CES anymore the most
noteworthy new stuff I saw actually came
from Huawei who randomly showed up with
a gold Nexus 6p which is such a subtle
gold but I guess totally still gold and
looks pretty good and their new Huawei
mate s which is a flagship phone with a
six inch display and a classic Huawei
skin on Android and supposedly a 2-day
battery life but let's be real I got a
test that before I trust the number in
anyway I did get to stop by Jaybirds
booth to get a look at their new
Bluetooth earbuds which are the jaybird
freedom and the x3 the x3 are a single
color matte finish with the new colors
and the freedom are an even smaller
super light weight bud where the earbud
itself is super small and then there's a
four hour battery in the controller that
can be extended by another little
wireless charger that holds four more
hours either way what's really dope
about these is the adjustable sound so
jaybird will have a my sound app that
you can install on your phone and there
you can adjust the EQ to your liking so
if you want more bass you can do that
more treble whatever you like and then
you save it as a preset now that would
normally be kind of lame but you don't
need the app anymore after you're done
with this so it's not happening through
the app you're actually modifying the
firmware in the earbuds so you can move
them over and pair them to something
else your iPad another phone whatever
you want and they'll still sound like
that preset you made that is pretty sick
alright so CES is often about the pixel
is not gonna lie but when I saw that
even Nikon dropped a DSLR that shoots 4k
video I was kind of surprised that's big
for them I kind of saw it as potential
YouTube gear nikon d 500 is a huge
improvement for them in video shoots 4k
video has an articulating LCD on the
back audio input for a my
HDMI out I mean it was nice a great
distraction actually from there way more
expensive but also kind of disappointing
d5 which on paper should have been nice
you know full frame and 4k video but
turns out it only shoots that 4k for up
to three minutes and it doesn't even use
the whole full frame that is not dope
tech Oh an icon also showed off a fork a
360 degree GoPro like action camera
complete with accessories and it kind of
looks like they really do care about
video again so all these 4k cameras have
been getting smaller and smaller and
smaller and Panasonic shows up at this
point with a 4k point and shoot
which reminded me of a certain Sony
camera I have raved about the rx100 so
the Panasonic's point shoot they've got
a viewfinder and articulating LCD a
programmable ring around the lens just
like the rx100 and it shoots 4k video
and it's all in a body that's just
slightly bigger than the rx100 so i'd
say this has the potential to be just as
good of a run-and-gun camera especially
if it doesn't overheat like the rx100 in
4k and especially for people who need
dad's zoom
trust me the lens is impressive but 4k
4k is everywhere everyone who makes a
screen has a 4k TV at CES and this is
one of those years that again only a few
just a few have an 8k TV and not gonna
lie I saw one that didn't even look that
good but I think it was because they
were playing like upscale 1080p content
or something like I literally don't
think they had any 8k video to show but
the killer for me here was the LG 98
inch
8k TV geez this looks good I mean it's
just pictures it's just a slideshow but
it looks so good like many of the things
that CES had no price tag no release
date and I was actually fine for me here
the desire is real the TV looked
incredibly detailed and then there was
this this would be the 8k TV of audio
the Sennheiser orpheus is a $50,000
audio listening experience now I'm sure
the difference in sound between this
$50,000 pair of headphones and a $5,000
pair of headphones is probably not
significant but I can tell you the
experience is the thing is nested in a
block of solid marble when you turn it
on the tubes from the tube amp literally
raised up from the case
and start to glow as they warm up the
cables are like ropes on the headphones
themselves are pretty huge but not
actually all that heavy and listening to
them even though I didn't get to pick
the songs was awesome you can check out
the TLD today channel for an entire
video just on trying to listen to these
trying to headphones on a couple other
youtubers getting a first listen bottom
line is it was pretty awesome my one
word summary of the listening experience
clean so clean I call it the 8k TV of
audio because let's be honest there's
got to be the content to even take
advantage of it and that pretty much
doesn't exist yet but of course there
were all kinds of other TVs at CES and
they all have their own acronyms to 4k
HD are super UHD 4k TV yeah let's just
say the best TV in my opinion was LG's
g6 super clean modern design with all
the electronics in the stand very thin
bezels and an incredible 4k OLED image
of course all sorts of other little
nuggets of dope tech around the show for
showed up at CES Audio Technica dropped
their eth a 990 z listen to him for
about 30 seconds but i need to again
hear my own music on them to make my own
judgement here and everyone had tablets
at the show normal sized tablets to
massive borderline TV sized tablets
that's an 18 inch Samsung tablet and
then super high-tech appliances trust me
this doesn't seem interesting but as a
person who's in the market for a
refrigerator these are hot and Kodak is
also making a super 8 film camera
bringing back the process and the
ability to shoot film so that was pretty
cool to see DJ I made a stealthy black
version of the inspire one which looks
like an absolute badass and there's also
now a phantom 3 that shoots 4k so the
drone game is clearly being stepped up
and Griffin showed up with one of my
favorite things a MagSafe USB type-c
charger so you 12 inch macbook users
you're probably thinking dan this is
exactly what Apple should have included
in the packaging but yeah Griffin went
out and made it and I couldn't be
happier it works great plus you can add
MagSafe to other USB C devices that
didn't even have it in the first place
and then there were the cars the real
ones and the concepts are both fair so
the Ford GT for example looked awesome
obviously there are plenty of other
great-looking
real cars all over the show floor Chevy
bolt showed up as in my opinion the
first actual rival to Tesla see we hear
that in the headlines all the time
I'm fired a future huh but this is a
real vehicle that's being made and at
under forty thousand bucks will have a
two hundred mile electric range so
that's pretty cool concept cars I put a
little bit less stock in even if they
are dope tech like the crazy Mercedes
concept self-driving car that was there
but the BMW i8 Spyder was there and
doorless and all looked pretty cool and
then there was the Faraday future car
yeah it was there but you know there you
go
CES is always quite the experience you
don't really go to CES to see the gadget
you're going to buy in a store tomorrow
you go to CES to catch a glimpse of the
future and sometimes you spot some dope
tech along the way needless to say I
will be back thanks for watching
I'll talk to you guys the next one peace